premier pas vers la liberté ce matin
lancé une vingtaine de chasseurs
réceptionne 1700 perdre au gris ces
oiseaux doivent rappeler les plaines du
nord du loir et cher
ils ont été sélectionnés dans un centre
d'élevage de seine maritime en raison de
leur souche dite sauvage
cela augure d'un meilleur instinct de
survie condition sinequanone pour ne pas
fragiliser les quelques perdre aux
survivants c'est quand d'élevage les
l'intestin est plus court
elle s'adapte beaucoup moins à l'état
sauvage parce que sont pas habitués de
se nourrir elles sont pas habitués à
différents facteurs canton les agents
milieux naturels notamment la prédation
et donc elles disparaissent très
rapidement en l'espace de 2-3 mois
coût de cette opération exceptionnelle
vingt mille euros entièrement financés
par la fédération de chasse et ses
adhérents à ce prix ce chasseur
préfèrent retarder le grand saut d'une
journée chez bec s'acclimate un
territoire qui couvre à télé loire après
le printemps quelle sa croupe donc une
pole est un copte après avoir faire des
petits territoires
cela fait au moins quarante ans que la
population de perdrix grise sauvage
diminue inexorablement sans que l'on ne
sache pourquoi les pesticides des
nouvelles méthodes d'agriculture le
réchauffement climatique sont montrés du
doigt mais ces six dernières années
c'est clairement les mauvaises
reproductions répétées qui met à mal la
survie de la perdrix grise l'année 2016
et de ce point de vue la pire jamais
enregistrée depuis le début des relevés
en 1978 le trop plein d'eau de mai et de
juin a détruit denim et noyé les yeux la
situation est critique mais ces
chasseurs ne baisse pas les bras
le but d'aider les gens c'est pas
obligatoirement que de koné que les
chasser ou que d'étirer ses devoirs des
oiseaux qui sont emblématiques de la
plaine céréalière de les voir toute
l'année et ça les gens sont prêts leçon
prêt à faire de gros efforts
par rapport à ça en général ça pose pas
de problème cette tentative de
régénération est aussi assortie d'une
interdiction de chasse pendant trois ans
à l'état naturel une perdrix grise
65 % de chances de passer l'hiver les
chasseurs espèrent qu'au moins 10% de
ces nouveaux venus vont survivre
jusqu'au printemps prochain
deux autres lâchers similaires vont être
organisées une fois par an jusqu'en 2018